hello everybody markiplier here um I
just wanted to take a second out of my
normal schedule to really stop and say
thank you to you guys because I know I
say thank you at the end of every video
that I do and but I feel like if I do
that over and over it loses its meaning
and it doesn't show how appreciative I
really am of you guys like I remember
back about four months ago or something
like that whenever I started it's a
little over four months now but later
into it I hit a thousand subscribers and
I was just I was flabbergasted is a good
word in this context that the response
that people had and it was like so many
of these so many people hundreds of
people had my back and were celebrating
everything I did and just were like
ecstatic that I was there for them and
it made me feel great in now four months
later the momentum hasn't stopped like
there's even more people now I can
literally say I have thousands of people
that enjoy what I do and that's an
incredible feeling but I
III never want to lose touch with what I
have and what I started with I think a
lot of youtubers when they get more
subscribers or more viewers they devalue
the individual like one person becomes
less valuable to them than others and I
I've always advocated if you've listened
in on my live streams you can't do
something like this and entertain people
and and forget who started you who
brought you up to where you are today
you can't lose focus on what that is and
I try not to do that because when I
started this out and I had maybe a
handful of subscribers in the tens you
know I I was honored to entertain those
10 people the original 15 is Elle column
and I I never want to lose sight of that
so I really wanted to take a second to
really truly and honestly thank you
each and every one of you for everything
that you've done
I mean we're coming up on 5,000
subscribers here and I'm going to do a
milestone video and I've actually got
something to give back to you guys for
all your help but I really just wanted
to take a second to really thank you
because I wouldn't be here if it wasn't
for you guys I wouldn't be anywhere near
where I am if it wasn't for you guys
helping me out on everything you've done
just commenting you know liking sharing
everything you've done to push me to
this point is incredible so really thank
you um thank you for that I I'm
blabbering now but I just want you to
know that from the bottom of my heart I
really do appreciate everything that you
guys have done for me so far so thank
you so much and I'm gonna end this
before I I just start blabbering on and
on because you guys know how much I can
talk about anything so thank you so much
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye